but what what does it mean that it feels
like the movies are back tonight you
know do you feel that
well i did until i got out of traffic
and i came right through that curtain
this really was impressive
it's been you know and to see you guys
kind of lined up and we all have this
weird relationship where we see you
you guys saying it feels back i'll trust
that
listen it does feel like a return to
like hollywood glamour and like you you
heard the people you walked in people
lost their minds
what does it mean though when you have
you know because the patentery of this
is amazing does it is it ever lost on
you does it ever get old to you i
watched my 12 year old daughter watch
her get dressed today in the room just
like this
she watched everything that happened she
saw the women and men around her i was
it was like a disney movie or something
but i watched her
and we brought her down to see something
we didn't know but her watching her mom
was pretty special
that is amazing that is cool
this is also the 25th anniversary of the
bodyguard 30th 30th of our 30th
anniversary what do you remember about
that and what do you remember about that
performance from whitney
well i remember she made up her mind
really
she's a she was a street smart girl she
knew stuff
and
i knew she could handle the part but she
wasn't sure she could handle it
and there came a moment where she had to
make a decision
and i saw her trust me
and we had that from that moment on
and
that was my promise to her that she
would look great
and be great she did and she looked
great she looked great all right can you
tell us anything about the next season
of yellowstone i mean folks are just
i mean it's their it's their drug of
choice producer asks you to say that but
you know how ridiculous that would be
for me to answer
that's a good point that's a good point
but
how in love people are with yellowstone
1883 the whole framework in 1932 isn't
that about to happen yeah well
i can't keep up with with all their
success i i show up i wear the hat
uh i you know i i've enjoyed being able
to do it we'll just see how long that
goes now i gotta get this moment because
this is beautiful from head to toe can
you tell me
this yes oh the dress is a tony ward
couture nice thank you so when you know
kevin told the story of your daughter
just watching you did you notice that
did you realize she was just like taking
she chose the dress she
from the start
she's good she's good she's included i
love it so much and by the way it's at
their wedding kevin was going to pick up
his marriage license i walked out in the
street and almost got hit by a car and
kevin pulled me up and pulled me out of
the way this was life
yeah it's been a minute i was happy too